Bitte schön.
Guten Abend. Mein Name ist Aktaqqa. Ich bin hier zuständig geärzt in Fürizi.
Zuerst werde ich zu Ihrer Person ein paar Fragen stellen, dann kommen wir gleich zu Ihrer Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie?
Ja, Verlockte, ich habe Ihren Namen nicht ganz verstanden. Ich bin schuldigung, ich bin etwas schwerhörig.
Aha. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich habe Ihren Namen nicht verstanden.
Mein Name ist Aktaqqa.
Okay, okay, jetzt habe ich es verstanden. Mein Name ist Hans Fischer.
Ich wohne hier in Frankfurt.
Hans Fischer.
Ja, richtig korrekt.
Herr Fischer, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 63 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Am 5. Juli 1961.
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ungefähr 1,70 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ungefähr 95 kg.
Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt oder Hausarztin?
Doktor Schäfer.
Ja, Doktor Schäfer.
Herr Fischer, was führt Sie zu uns heute?
Ich habe Beschwerden in meinem Bein.
Da habe ich im rechten Bein Schmerzen.
Das ist auch im Unterschenkel.
Auch geschwollen und auch rot.
Dazu muss ich sagen, ich hatte vor einem Jahr schon meine Thrombose gehabt in dem Bein.
Ich hatte schon mal Beschwerden, aber das war ein bisschen anders als jetzt, fand ich.
Das sind die Ursachen für meine Bein.
Wann war diese Thrombose für einen Jahr?
Ungefähr einem Jahr.
Und seit wann haben Sie diese Schmerzen?
Seit gestern, vorgestern.
Zwei Tage fast.
Wie sind diese Beschwerden, diese Schmerzen aufgetreten langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Die sind eher langsam aufgetreten, nicht sofort.
Ich habe sie schon mal begonnen.
Wie ist die Schmerzen im rechten Unterschenkel?
Im Unterschenkel.
Oder im Unterschenkel?
Der gesamte Unterschenkel.
Und es ist jetzt auch rot.
Und es ist geräutet.
Und geschwollen?
Ja.
Strellen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
In den Fuß ein bisschen, aber ansonsten unterschenken.
Gibt es etwas, das diese Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Zum Beispiel Hochlageung oder...
Also ich habe es jetzt hochgelagert, ist vielleicht ein bisschen besser geworden, aber nicht so viel.
Und ich habe auch Schmerzmedikamente eingenommen, die ich zu Hause hatte wegen meiner Schulterarthrose,
nämlich über Profäen, das habe ich genommen, hat ein bisschen geholfen.
Wie stark sind diese Profäen?
400.
400? Einmal haben Sie genommen?
Ich habe jetzt zweimal genommen, gestern Abend, morgen nochmal.
Und ein bisschen hier?
Ein bisschen weniger, aber es ist nicht weg.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Sind diese Schmerzen eher dumpf, drückend oder siehend, stehend?
Also ich würde sie erst dumpf und drückend beschreiben.
Und wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkadafone 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leichter und 10 sehr starker Schmerzen entspricht?
Ja, so 5, 6 würde ich mal sagen.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nein, die sind eigentlich dauerhaft da.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Langgäre mit dem Auto oder Flug gemacht?
Nein, für Doktor, ich war nicht verweist.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit einen Unfall?
Unfall? Nein, ich hatte keinen Unfall.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit viel Gesessen oder gestanden?
Ich würde sagen so wie immer, also nichts Besonderes.
Okay.
Haben Sie eine Gerinnungsstörung oder bestätigt eine in Ihrer Familie?
Nein, das ist damals getestet worden.
Vor einem Jahr habe ich Gerinnungsstörung, aber nichts festgestellt worden.
Okay.
Haben Sie Luftnotarfische?
Nein.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen oder Husten?
Nein, habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Taubheitsgefühl oder Kribbeln bemerkt in Fuß oder anderen Beinen?
Taubheitsgefühl.
Aha, oder Kribbeln?
Kribbeln.
Ja, kann ich so nicht sagen, es fühlt sich zwar anders an, aber es ist kein Taubheitsgefühl, kann ich nicht sagen.
Okay.
Es fühlt sich anders an, weil es vielleicht ein bisschen geschwollend ist, aber ansonsten ist es ein bisschen normal.
Können Sie sagen Spannungsgefühl?
Ja, Spannungsgefühl.
Haben Sie Krampfwörtern?
Nein, ich habe keine Krampfwörtern.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sie fliebdicht?
Also ich habe heute Morgen in der Tat erhöhte Temperatur gemessen, das war 37,8.
37,8?
Ja.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Also nicht so gut seit gestern, bis nach Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Erbrochen?
Ja, ich habe eigentlich Erbrochen einmal, ja.
Heute Morgen habe ich aber zu schnell einen Kaffee getrunken, vielleicht lag es auch daran.
Und ich habe Kopfhörer.
Wie sagt das Erbrochen aus?
Also, nicht so auffällig so.
Hat das Essenwäste enthalten?
Ja, also nichts besonderes.
War auch nur wenig.
Haben Sie auch Duftwörter?
Nein, ich habe keine Durchwörter.
Okay.
Haben Sie Nachtschweiß?
Nein.
Oder Schweiß aus Brühe?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, ist relativ konstant.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise ja, seit gestern ein bisschen Probleme, aber sonst schlafe ich gut.
Sie haben Probleme beim Schlafen wegen dieser Schmerz?
Ja, richtig.
Haben Sie normalerweise Probleme, aber dann schlafen Sie die Schlafen?
Eigentlich nicht, Frau Doktor.
Okay, kaffee.
Und jetzt möchte ich wissen, ob Sie reagieren allergisch,
irgendeinem Verhältnis, bestimmte Medikamente oder Lebensmitteln?
Kann ich mich nicht erinnern?
Sie haben keine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeit?
Ich habe nichts bekannt.
Okay.
Frau Scha, jetzt möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe das mit der Thrombose gesagt, glaube ich.
Vor einem Jahr, das war es.
Ja, da habe ich auch ein halbes Jahr lang Medikamente genommen.
Perche Medikamente haben Sie eigentlich?
Ja, erst einmal muss ich Spritzen machen.
Und dann habe ich Tabletten genommen.
Das ist Eliquis, habe ich genommen.
Eliquis.
Wie viele Milligramm war es da?
5 Milligramm war es anders.
Aber die nehme ich seit einem halben Jahr nicht mehr.
Das sollte ich nur ein halbes Jahr nehmen.
Und ich habe auch Diabetes.
Wobei der Zucker jetzt seit gestern auch ein bisschen höher war.
Ich nehme da Tabletten regelmäßig ein.
Wer für Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen Zuckerkrankheit ein?
Also das einmales Jahr, Jahr Dijans.
Könnten Sie bitte wiederholen?
Jahr Dijans.
Und Medformin.
Nämlich morg zu abends.
Wie stark?
1000 Medformin.
Das ist ein 5 Milligramm morgens.
5 Milligramm morgens.
Und leiden Sie noch an,
wer hier noch andere erkannt hat.
Also Bluthochdruck ist bekannt?
Ich auch Medikamente ein.
Werche Medikamente nehmen Sie gegen?
Ramilich plus.
Nämlich eine Tablette morgens ein.
Und wie stark ist diese?
5 Milligramm morgens.
Nehmen Sie ein.
Nehmen Sie auch diese Medikamente.
Wegen der Schulteratrose, die ich habe,
nehme ich ab und zu Ibuprofen ein.
Nehmen ich auch, wenn ich Ibuprofen nehme,
auch einen Magenschutz, Pantoprazol.
Pantoprazol 20 Milligramm.
Die 20 ja.
Aber Nubal bedarf nicht immer.
Ibuprofen und Pantoprazol, Nubal bedarf.
Ibuprofen ist 400 Milligramm.
400 Milligramm, hat ich gesagt.
Sie leiden an Zuckerkrankheit,
Bluthochdruck.
Und haben vor einem Jahr
eine Trombose im rechten Unterschenkel.
Rechten Bein ja.
Nehmen Sie aspirin ein?
Nein.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Als junger Mann, blinder.
Wann war das?
Da war ich 19, 20 Jahre alt.
Und das war komplikationslos gelaufen?
Ja.
Hatten Sie noch andere Operationen?
Keine andere Operationen.
Nur diese Bilfdarmung?
Ja.
Herr Fischer, rauchen Sie?
Ich habe geraucht, ich habe vor 10 Jahren aufgehört.
Sie haben sehr gute Entscheidungen getroffen,
mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören.
Und davor, wie viele Zigaretten am Tag
und wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Ich habe so ungefähr 30 Jahre lang geraucht,
aber nicht viel, das waren maximal ein halbes Päckchen pro Tag.
30 Jahre lang?
Ungefähr, ja.
Eine halbe Schatte? Ja.
Herr Fischer, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, so zum Essen, eine Flasche Bier vielleicht mal,
und dann ein Tag.
Und ich gucke, dass ich Alkohol weiß,
weil ich wegen der Kalorien noch aufpassen muss.
Ein Flasche Bier, gelegentlich?
Ja.
Wie viel Mal pro Woche können Sie sagen?
Also 3-4 Mal vielleicht.
Und Herr Fischer, bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Routine Mesih, muss ich Sie fragen,
ob Sie irgendwer ein Kontakt mit Rogen hatten oder haben?
Nein, ich nehme keinen Rogen.
Okay, das ist so gut.
Herr Fischer, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Beamter im Finanzamt.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, verheiratet.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, 2 Kinder, sind aber schon erwachsen.
Sind Sie gesund, Ihre Kinder?
Ja, die Kinder sind gesund.
Herr Fischer, Leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Der Vater ist verstorben, die Mutter lebt noch.
Woran ist Ihr Vater verstorben?
Der Vater ist früher ein Arbeitsunterfass gestorben.
Wann war das?
Da war er ungefähr, also schon sehr lange her,
da war er ungefähr 50, 60 Jahre alt.
Das war schon ein bisschen vor 40 Jahren.
Und Ihre Mutter, ist sie gesund?
Die hat auch ein paar Krankheiten, also auch Zucker.
Sie hat auch Bluthochdruck wie ich.
Und wenn sie Herzprobleme haben,
dann auch Stands bekommen.
Das sind so die Krankheiten, die die Mutter hat.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich bin ein kleines Kind gewesen.
Herr Fischer, sind Sie alle geblieben?
Alle Kinder, Krankheiten und Covid19 geimpft?
Covid19, ja.
Aber die anderen Impfungen, die kontrolliert man haus,
hat dabei nichts gesagt, dass ich eine Impfung ins neue berichter.
Ich habe jetzt im Herbst Influenza
und Covid-Impfung bekommen.
Okay.
Treiben Sie Legale und Sport?
Eigentlich nicht nein.
Können Sie Ihren Bein in alle Richtungen normal bewegen?
Ja, das kann ich.
Es tut weh, wenn ich das belaste.
Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen.
Müssen Sie beim Laufen stechenbleiben
oder eine Pause machen?
Aktuell oder?
Aktuell.
Aktuell laufe ich nicht, weil das dann wehtut beim Laufen.
Wie weit können Sie laufen ohne diese Schmerzen zu bekommen?
Ich habe ja dauerhaft Schmerzen, deswegen
ich probiere jetzt nicht zu laufen.
Ich habe mich ausgeruht.
Und diese Schmerzen sind bei Bewegung schlimmer?
Wir werden ein bisschen mehr.
Beben Sie Haarausfall bemerkt an Ihrem Bein?
Haarausfall am Bein? Nein.
Beben Sie Geschwüre im Bein?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Aber ich hatte vor einer Woche mal
eine Entzündung am Nage, am Fuß.
Das ist jetzt wieder besser geworden.
Wie war diese Entzündung?
Es war so wie ein eingewachsener Nage.
Am Fuß war so gerötet.
Ein bisschen weiter war auch da.
Aber dann ist es wieder besser geworden.
Vor einer Woche war es ungefähr.
Beben Sie irgendwelche Medikamente
gegen diese Entzündung?
Nein, ich habe da das normalen Schlagzeuge angeht.
Beben Sie einen Arzt aufgesucht?
Nein, das war nicht so stark.
Das war nur eine leichte Entzündung.
Herr Schär, jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ich habe alle wichtigen Fragen gestellt.
Können Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich frage, ob ich im Krankenhaus bleiben muss.
Meinen Sie, dass man ambulant behandelt?
Jetzt kann ich nichts sagen.
Zuerst sind einige Untersuchungen erforderlich.
Dann besprechen wir die weiteren Schritte.
Jetzt werde ich sie körperlich untersuchen.
Und etwas Blut abnehmen.
Für Laboruntersuchungen.
Vielleicht ein Ultraschall.
Sonografie.
Ultraschall notwendig sein kann.
Sie wissen, ich denke, diese Ultraschall-Untersuchung.
Ultraschall ist ohne Strahlung, oder?
Ultraschall-Untersuchung ist strahlenfrei.
Ich hatte letztes Jahr viele Strahlung gehabt.
Deswegen für mich das Problem.
Ich habe das Problem.
Warum hat sie viel Strahlung?
Da haben die Trombose Untersuchungen gemacht.
Mit Kontrastmittel und Geränsch.
Ich verstehe.
Ultraschall ist strahlenfrei.
Frau Doktor, ich bin ja auch versiert über die Beamtenversicherung.
Ich habe auch Schäffahrtsbehandlung.
Wissen Sie das Wissen?
oder brauchen Sie dafür einen Unterlagen?
Ich habe Schäffahrtsbehandlung.
Brauchen Sie etwas?
Nein, ich brauche nicht.
Okay.
Jetzt würde ich sie bitten,
noch einmal kurz in der Artisan-Amto.
Okay.
Wir werden sie
in
innen,
um mit der Untersuchung anfangen.
Okay. Alles klar.
Beim letzten Mal, als ich im Krankenhaus war,
da musste ich etwas unterschreiben für Chefarzt Bandung,
Wahlleistungsvertrag.
Machen Sie das nicht diesmal?
Da musste ich so einen Vertrag unterschreiben.
Wahlleistungsvertrag.
Brauche ich das wieder?
Ich denke, dass ich nicht brauche.
Ich brauche nicht.
Ich frage mich allen Kollegen.
Alles klar.
Es gibt Fragen von den Kollegen, die die Kommentare haben.
Ja.
Ich denke, die Details haben wir auch nicht verblüht.
Aber es ist auch eine Art und Weise,
die wir in der Küche haben.
Ich habe es auch nicht verblüht.
Aber wenn es in der Offene gibt oder nicht gefragt ist,
Sie haben nach Geschwürren gefragt.
Geschwürren?
Ja.
Sie haben kein Geschwürren,
nur vor einer Woche, zehn Tage,
so eine Paronistik, so etwas.
Paronistik.
So etwas in der Richtung.
Okay.
Ja.
Ich habe es.
Ja, okay.
Bitte schön.
Haben Sie abgeschlagen heute?
Ja, er fühlt sich allgemein etwas krank.
Aber aktuell vorher nicht.
Hat auch Kopfschmerzen und allgemeine Beschwerden.
Und Temperatur, Fieber, leicht.
Können Sie die Farbe der Haut beschreiben?
Ist es rot oder levide Verwärmung?
Es ist rot.
Scharf oder unscharf begrenzt?
Scharf begrenzt.
Und haben Sie in den letzten Seiten Husten?
Keine Husten hat Sie gefragt.
Husten ist noch nicht gewesen.
Husten ist mir gar nicht.
Nichts gemerkt.
Ja.
Okay.
Gut.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind sehr durch.
Können wir als Herzgespieler anfangen?
Ja, alle verstanden.
Vielleicht, bevor Sie mit dem Herz-Arztgespiel anfangen,
was ist die Verdachtdiagnose bei den Patienten?
Mein Verdachtdiagnose ist erzibelt.
Genau.
Und Differenzialdiagnosen, die Ihnen spontan einfallen, dazu?
Die Fatih, die Verenanthromose.
Also, Rethe Fatih.
Also, es hat ja gehabt, ja.
Okay, was noch?
Ja.
Macht PAVK Rötung, oder?
Ja, diese ist unwahrscheinlich.
Aber als Differenzialdiagnosen kann ich sagen.
Was noch?
Außer R-Sipel, TVT.
Zellulitis.
Oder Tromboflebitis.
Oder Fleckmone kann auch mal sein.
Alles klar.
Gut, dann können wir anfangen. Bitte schön.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen einen Patienten vorstellen,
den ich gerade eben in der Note aufnahme gesehen habe.
Ja.
Herr Hansfischer, 83 Jahre alt,
170 cm groß,
95 kg schwer.
Der Patient stellt sich bei uns
für aufgrund seit ein bis zwei Tagen
5-tähernder Langsam aufgetretener
Schmerzen im rechten Unterchenkel.
So wie erüttem, begleitet der Patient,
nausea und einmeilige Emesis
und ödem im rechten Unterchenkel.
Der Patient hat eine Schmerz-Sepfung.
Die Schmerzen sind dauerhaft.
Der Patient hat ein Profen,
400 mg, 2-mal eingenehm.
Mit geringen Ansprüchen.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
Die Frage ist,
ob die Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
ob die Schmerzen
auf der Schmerz-Sepfung sind.
ist nicht rauch er seit 10 Jahren.
Dafür habe er 15 Pakumusjahr geraucht.
Er trinkt gelegentlich 3-4 Mal Provohe, eine Flasche Bier.
Er sei beämter vom Beruf, verheiratet und habe zwei gesunde Erwachsene Kinder.
In der Familienanamnese sei bekannt, der Vater sei vor Langen an Arbeit und
Fall verstorben und die Mutter leidte an Diabetes-Militus-Typ2, Arteriallihibatoni
und Coronare-Härtskrankheiten.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik hatte ich
einen Moment, wenn Sie seit haben, können Sie uns zusammenfassen?
Die Kollegin hat es ganz gut gemacht bisher, lassen Sie ruhig weiter erzählen.
Aber Obererstich, Chefarzt zusammenfassen ist.
Ich mache zum Schluss dann nochmal.
Okay.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich dann verdacht auf ein Erusipel.
Als Differenzialdiagnosen kommen TFT und Plobutrombose in Betracht.
Okay.
Und wegen meines Verdacht führte ich zuerst eine Körperlihe und Terzuchung.
Dabei hatte ich besonders auch bei Inspektionen
ob er dann scharfe oder umscharfe ist und palpiere ich das Bein, ob es warm oder kalt ist, ob es Ödeme gibt.
Und danach legte ich einen Venösenzugang und nehme gleichzeitig Blut ab.
Aus dem Blut möchte ich ein kleines Blutbild CRP, BSG, D-Dimer, Gerinnungsparameter,
gegebenenfalls eine farbkodierte Duplex-Kongression Sonografie notwendig kann sein.
Was machen Sie noch, wenn Sie Blut abnehmen, außer den genannten Sachen?
Was ist denn die Ursache für Ihre vermutet Diagnose?
Stryptococ.
Was ist die häufigste Erregung?
Stryptococospiogenis.
Ja, Alpamiricine Stryptococcus sind häufigste, gelingensamte.
Aber ja, was würden Sie da nochmal untersuchen, wenn Sie schonmal Blut abnehmen?
Hatt ich gedacht, dass es bei Ihnen als erstes kommt, aufgrund Ihrer Vorerfahrung?
Könnt man Sie bitte wiederholen?
Was würden Sie noch, wenn Sie Blut abnehmen, machen, untersuchen?
Anti-Stryptolis.
Machen, aber noch?
Sie haben noch eine Mikrobiologie gearbeitet, haben Sie gesagt.
Ja. Was machen Sie denn?
Was machen Mikrobiologen gerne?
Oder andersrum gefragt?
Dann nicht derinnert.
Welches An... Sie müssen ja dann...
Sie würden ja wie behandeln den Patienten, wenn Sie jetzt von Erreysipäle ausklingen?
Wie behandeln Sie den Patienten?
Mit Antibiotikoterapie.
Welche?
Ich werde einen Antibiotikotest durchführen.
Wie machen Sie Antibiotikotest?
Blutkultur.
Ja, das wollte ich von Ihnen hören.
Sie machen eine Blutkultur,
ob Bakterien wachsen, genau.
Ja, so ist es.
Ich werde dann alle Gerbischte durchführen und machen einen Antibiotikotest.
Genau, aber das dauert ja meistens ein bisschen,
deswegen fangen Sie auch schon vor dem Antibiotikotest mit der Therapie.
Wenn ein Patient eine Penicillinallergie hat, was machen Sie dann?
Kann ich Sepholosuporin?
Ein Beispiel, ja, eine Option.
Genau.
Erste Generation.
Alles klar, also Blutabgenommen haben Sie, Blutkultur abgenommen, richtig.
Mit auch einem Antibokram, wenn kein Max drum ist.
Und jetzt haben Sie gesagt, noch Apparativuntersurung, machen Sie Dubluxsonografie.
Warum machen Sie Dubluxsonografie?
Ich möchte tiefer, wenn ein Thrombose ausschließen.
Ja, die hatte er schon gehabt im Jahr.
Was machen Sie jetzt?
Wenn Sie jetzt das in tiefer Bein, wie ein Thrombose sehen,
was hilft Ihnen das weiter jetzt?
Ich würde Sie bitte wiederholen.
Ja, der Patient hatte vor allem schon eine tiefe Bein.
Wenn Sie jetzt Ultraschall machen,
und Sie sehen eine Bein-Win-Thrombose,
dann sehen Sie eine Bein-Win-Thrombose.
Das hilft Ihnen weiter in Ihrer Diagnostik.
Ich kann eine neue Thrombose sehen.
Ja, zum Beispiel, wie sieht man die?
Enbolie oder?
Enbolie wäre dann die Folge der Thrombose.
Normalerweise ist es ja so, wenn eine Thrombose da ist,
dann ist es ja oft so, dass dann dieses Blutgefäß verschlossen bleibt,
wird organisiert und dann bieten sich Kollateralkreisläufe
und diese Winne bleibt zu.
Manchmal geht es ja wieder auf, haben Sie recht,
aber es bleibt halt zu.
Wenn Sie jetzt noch mal Ultraschall machen,
dann sehen Sie eine Winne, die verschlossen ist.
Wie wissen Sie, ob es Frisch verschlossen oder Chronisch verschlossen ist?
Ich weiß nicht.
Wenn Sie zum Beispiel so frei flottierende Thrombosanteile sehen,
das könnte hinweisen auf frische Thrombose.
Ansonsten kann es sein, dass Sie einfach eine Thrombose sehen,
dann wissen Sie nicht, ob es Alte oder Neues.
Dann wissen Sie nicht, ob es die Ursache dafür ist.
Kann sein.
Was machen Sie noch?
Reicht das dann?
Ich glaube, es wird reichen.
Klar macht man doch bei jeder Patientin EKG vielleicht noch mal,
aber ansonsten würde ich es auch keine weitere operative Diagnostik machen.
Das Bild ist meistens eindeutig bei Erisipäel.
Wenn es zu scharf begrenzt ist, gerötet ist,
dann ist das die Verdachssegnose, die den Antibolch behandeln können.
Aber habe keine Beschwerden, Herzdosen oder Herzstufen?
Hat er nicht, aber also EKG macht es,
sollte man immer schreiben, klar,
weil man es keine weitere Untersuchung,
wenn der Patient keine anderen Beschwerden hat.
Und was machen Sie?
Schicken Sie den Patienten nach Hause oder bleibt im Krankenhaus?
So weiter in Aufklärung möchte ich der Patientstationär aufnehmen.
Den würde ich auch stationär aufnehmen.
Was sind denn bei den Patienten predisponierende Faktoren
für ein Erisipäel aus der Anamnese?
Haben Sie da ein paar Angaben, die Sie dazu leiten?
Ich habe vergisst das sagen.
Er hatte eine gewachsene Nagel.
Genau, das zum Beispiel ist ein Faktor,
eine Wunde, eine Antrittsquote für Keime, richtig?
Und er leidet auch an Diabetes Miniatur 2.
Genau, das ist auch ein Faktor, richtig?
War es noch predisponierend für so eine Diagnose?
Ist der Patient schlank?
Ja, ja.
Also Adipositas ist auch noch mal ein Risikofaktor.
Das wären so Hinweise, wo Sie aus der Anamnese herausschauen,
die Verdachtsdiagnose haben können.
Alles klar, gut.
So, haben wir alles besprochen.
Haben Sie den Patienten unterscheiden lassen für Wahlleistung?
Ja, ich weiß es.
Ich habe mich nicht geschrieben, ich zahle nicht.
Deswegen habe ich es am Anfang gefragt.
Wahlleistungspatienten müssen einen Wahlleistungsvertrag unterschreiben.
Wenn ich nicht unterscheide,
darf das Krankenhaus keine privaterzigen Rechnung stellen.
Deswegen sind die immer sehr stark dahinter,
dass die Patienten sofort, wenn sie ins Krankenhaus kommen,
bevor der ist untersuchen, läuft, gleich unterscheiden.
Wahlleistungspatienten müssen einen Wahlleistungsvertrag unterschreiben.
Wahlleistungsvertrag unterschreiben.
Wahlleistung, ja.
Oder Privatärztin oder Chefarztin.
Das habe ich damit fragen wollen.
Gut.
Okay, haben wir alle wichtige Sachen gesagt?
Wahlleistung.
Ich werde erst mal aufgehört.
Privatpatientin oder Chefarztin.
Was für ein
Patient kann auswahlen.
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Dann der Patient kann Chefarzt auswahlen.
Richtig, genau.
Und wenn er nicht unterschreibt,
dann kann das Krankenhaus auch keine Chefarztrechnung stellen.
Deswegen ist die Verwaltung dahinter,
dass die sobald sie ins Krankenhaus kommen
und bevor die ersten Maßnahmen erfolgen, sie unterschreiben.
Das kann man sich nicht in die Rechnung stellen.
Geld regiert die Welt.
Genau.